so the talk title is lessons learned
from evaluating the robustness of
Defense's data so examples this is a
little bit long and I'm gonna go through
my talk
sort of backwards and I'm gonna start
talking about episode examples then talk
about defenses then talk about
evaluating the robustness of these
defenses and then the lessons we learned
from that now okay we've done this
enough so I figured I'd show you a new
picture this one you haven't seen before
it's another picture this is true okay
we can all move on good okay
so how do we generate adversarial
examples we've seen a little bit of this
from the math perspective what I want to
do is show you a little bit of pictures
that I find helpful in just sort of
understanding what's going on in the
space okay so what I'm showing you here
is the actual decision boundary analysis
of a c4 neural network so I have in the
middle here some image of a dog each
pixel here corresponds to the
classification where I'm color coding
the classification to each of the ten
different classes as I go in one axis I
add one type of noise and as I go on the
other axis to add an orthogonal type of
noise in pixel space so you'll see for
example this is an image that is also a
modified version of that dog but I've
added a huge amount of noise to it and
it's now classified incorrectly as a
truck because it's in this dark blue
reached before I go anywhere is it clear
what this picture is showing so if I
move in two random directions and as I
move away I no longer in this light blue
region I'm no longer being classified as
dog these are two random directions I
picked one I picked one I picked the
other one to be orthogonal to the first
now in high dimensions everything I
thought was a thought anyway but I do
just to be be sure okay so now yeah
pixel space just direct pixel space I
just sort of added a random amount of
noise and went in that direction
okay there are three colors okay so
there are actually more than three
colors that you can't really see clearly
on this so this plate that this region
here is dog the one around it is
airplane and then the dark blue is truck
no I guess some of you on maybe the
other monitor can see that there's
actually a different color region here
and there you just can't see on this one
but it doesn't really matter that much
the basic idea is one to show you is I'm
adding a huge amount of noise to get
this just incorrect label and that's
nothing I don't care like I can't
actually tell what that image is without
knowing that that was the original image
so even though I guided the large amount
of noise I'm okay with that this is not
an episode example to me okay so the
basic idea of what we like to say in
episode examples is I'm going to pick
some small boundary that is contained
within the area and say can the
adversary find something within this
small box which is misclassified and in
two dimensions the answer here is no and
I can just enumerate all of them but of
course this picture is a lie you know
we're actually in a 3000 dimensional
space and so I can pick a different axis
and the image will look like this so I'm
continuing this y-axis to be the same
but now the x axis is different it's now
the worst-case direction and now if I
draw if I can like find this point here
is now an airplane I've sort of extended
the green region here and if I put the
box around it like it's within the box
so this is the problem basically I've
episode examples is that in random
directions you you're safe everything is
fine but if I picked the worst-case
direction then it's very easy to find an
episode example it's sort of like most
of the space
okay so now what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna do one more thing to this picture
and I'm going to extend it to be
three-dimensional well I'm going to do
this I'm going to make the z-axis be the
confidence of the neural network in the
correct prediction so one more time just
so it's clear it's all going to make the
same image but I'm gonna make it be
three-dimensional and the third axis is
going to be the confidence of them
they're all networked in the correct
prediction yes yes right no it's not
actually like this not actually it's not
of course models are calibrated well but
as far as it reports to me I'm going to
use the users as a proxy for confidence
in the correct prediction so this this
point here at the very top is when is is
the image which it believes is
definitely the label dog and the
important thing to note is that in this
adversarial example in this episode
Direction sort of going one way it
doesn't really change the prediction
very much but going the other way
very very very quickly if you do
gradient descent will let you find an
avalanche the classification and bring
the confidence down basically to zero so
like this image this point here
corresponds to an image which has not
changed basically at all but the
confidence that its dog is now zero a
softmax prediction in the label dog
basis I mean okay this picture is and
again I'm lying to you but yes so this
is the initial image right here and then
it because because of Lipschitz constant
is enormous
it can very very quickly decrease and it
is close to the boundary yes I would
expect there to the peak to be at the
center of the classic we classify it one
of the dimension is the worse so this
term exit direction is the worst-case
direction
it's the adversarial direction so like
if I go back to here right
in this way I can go up or down quite
far before the label changes this is
this is a random direction which in high
dimensions like an interesting fact if
this is basically flat on the left right
okay yeah maybe it would be right if I
was doing the right thing maybe but it's
not is the argument we're making and yes
this is an actual picture from a trained
ResNet of what it actually does like I'm
not sort of lying in respect to that yes
how steep in this clip here no drop if
you look if you look at this I see okay
so the height here corresponds to
confidence in dog right yes okay so so I
can so what it would so so there would
be an inverse image here so if you would
look if I were instead where to show you
what the so okay so so this one here
this green is classified as airplane if
I were to show you the other image which
was confidence in airplane you'd have
another big giant spike right here
so the image that I'm going towards is
optimizing towards airplane does that
answer your question
kind of
okay so the argument I just want to make
is that first creative dissent is very
easy to us all I mean like this was a
very nice surface it's very easy to
optimize over I just sort of compute
gradient descent and we very quickly
find an average still example which is
very high quality that's the first thing
I want to make clear the other thing I
want to make clear is that it's not like
this like just isolated pockets of
adversarial myths that are sort of
isolated at least when you look at this
in low dimension that there are these
large surfaces where you can go and once
I've gone here I can travel in this
orthogonal direction and it remains the
adversarial class ok yes so this one has
so this applies only to dimensions there
are papers that that estimate the
dimensionality of the adversarial
subspace and find it's around like 30
dimensional or something right which is
which is still very exponential in what
is hard a little hard to define it's 30
dimensional in a 3,000 dimensional space
so it's a small fraction of that but
it's not like an isolated pocket like
they're connected regions that
the fact that men assembly methods do
not my name is Shirley temple's sale
idiom bill abate volume vanishingly
small
okay so that's why sure
yes I will agree with this statement
okay so all of this is just to show sort
of a visual intuition of what's going on
here like gradient descent is great
finding these things and it's sort of
next I'm just and this okay so now let
me sort of talk about something
different which is threat models just
very briefly so when we typically state
adversarial examples we are like drawing
this box and say you must be within this
box and the reason we do that is because
we want to make sure that you don't
perturb the image by too much if you
change the image by a lot obviously you
can change its classification for
non-constant functions so a threat model
is sort of a formal statement that
defines when a system is intended to be
secure typically we'll say that you know
I might say okay like my system is is
where bust when the l2 distortion is
less than five and then I have this
other caveat that like given the
attacker has white box knowledge and
what this means is for the remainder of
the talk I'm going to assume that the
person who's trying to generate these
Eversole examples knows everything there
is to know about the defended model this
is the assumption I've made which was
also made by the prior talks I just want
to make this explicit there are other
assumptions you can make like maybe the
attacker doesn't have access to the
model weights and that could be
realistic you know when I was at
university I didn't have access to the
classifier that Google was using and so
I might know the type of thing they were
using I might know that they're probably
using some inception network but I might
not know exactly the values of the
trained weights I'm going to assume that
I know everything about it I know all of
the weights and everything don't you for
threat model then you can make some kind
of claim and say that I'm claiming that
under this threat model I have 90%
accuracy
okay so just to show again I might have
my thermal be this box and so the
basically the idea is that you know I'm
adding some small perturbation the
perturbation I added is basically almost
so small you can barely see it here is
that a little bit of gray yeah it's
better it's easier those are my star
contrasts but yeah so this is the idea
is that I'm doing something small I want
to make one sort of side observation
which is that it's important to make
sure this region is small enough so
people ok so here's here's another thing
you can do this images in the test set
it's classified as an 8 I can introduce
a fairly large perturbation so that all
of us would label this as a 3 but the
classifier is invariant to perturbations
and classifies this as an 8 which is now
wrong I like done the other thing like I
have made the humans label switch but
the classifiers label not switch this is
also an attack I'm not going to talk
about this kind of thing though but I
just want to put this up briefly just to
sort of push back a little bit on the
provable claims so you know there was a
comment that you know you can prove that
I can't defeat your classifier by making
the function constant in some large
region if the claim was very strong then
it might be so strong that you now lose
against this time tube adversary where
you certify that you're never going to
change within radius 5 and I make a
change of radius 5 now that the human
label changes but like yours classifiers
label doesn't change now it turns out
today we're safe and we're not yet going
above that but you can't just keep on
growing these balls indefinitely and
eventually we'll reach a problem where
now the human label changes in the
classifiers level doesn't change and
again you're wrong it's not that kind of
episode right yes no definitely this is
but yeah this is the this is the
observation just like you can't just
keep throwing these balls but
he because you can have like one word of
not exactly yes this is why in in in NLP
we don't like using LP norms because
yeah I invert the the word you know the
movie was great the movie was awful
I'm differ in one word but they'd
actually do a different sentiment yeah
okay okay so this is the type of thing
I'm going to be talking about just small
perturbations that could change the
classifier but not the human so defense
is to have a so examples then so defense
for my purpose satisfies two properties
it's good on the test set and it resists
adverse so examples things that I want
I'm going to talk about the
non-certified defenses in this talk
because the certified defense is as long
as the proof is correct everything in
the paper is true there's a what I'm
going to talk about this talk is the non
certified variants which are people who
propose something saying this is the
defense to adversely examples without a
proof and the question there is is it
correct and that's what makes those
defenses very difficult okay so let me
give you a couple examples of what
defenses you might think of we've seen
adversarial training before so I'm going
to skip through basically all of it
because I don't want to bore you okay
episode training is done
okay one more defense that you might
consider this was a paper that was
proposed at iclear last year
it's called thermometer encoding the
claim is that neural networks are
overlay linear there are linear in
regions where they shouldn't be linear
and so we're going to break this
linearity and hopefully this is going to
help solve adversarial examples and the
way we're gonna do that is I'm going to
create a thermometer encoding input so
if I have my pixel value was 0.13 I'm
now going to make the input be someone's
followed by zeros if was 0.66 then I do
more ones followed by some zeros and if
it was like point nine seven then it's
all ones so you know it's like reading a
thermometer value and now this hopefully
breaks the linearity of the inputs and
allows the neural network to learn to be
nonlinear in interesting ways and
prevent that
examples this is one proposal that I'll
come back to or you could imagine that
maybe I do some input transformations
you know maybe perturbations are brittle
and so I'm gonna take my image of a cat
and then I'll rotate it randomly and
then pin it to my neural network or all
you know JPEG compress it and then feed
it through my neural network something
else like this these are all variants of
Defense's that we've seen and I'll come
back to both of these in a little bit so
is it clear by everyone but I mean I
have a so examples and by defensive
temporal examples so what does it mean
to evaluate the robustness of an offense
type it's all examples then so the basic
standard ml pipeline goes like this you
know you train your model you then you
sort of could get the accuracy by
evaluating it on the test set and then
you know if the accuracy is good enough
you can say you know state of the art
and if it's not good enough they're like
you know who do more hyper far more
tuning or something okay so okay so so
in you know this step is very easy this
is the straightforward step in most
evaluations like you just compute the
accuracy on the test set as long as you
didn't train on the test set basically
you can't cheat and you know the talk on
Monday was very nice and showing that we
haven't even over fit the test set over
the last 10 years of doing CFR
evaluations you despite the fact that
you might think you may have okay so
yeah this is the like it's very
straightforward to do this and robust
test evaluations change this one line
and make one different change which is
to run an attack on the test set and the
only thing that I'm doing in a
robustness evaluation is constructing
this function a like I play the role of
the adversary I try and make the worst
test that possible to make your
classifier wrong and that is the only
change that I'm doing to make this a
robust evaluation but it like coming up
with this function is not as non-trivial
like I have to make sure that I think
very hard and break the specific defense
which is being evaluated yeah
attack depend but this what you wrote
here suggests the attack doesn't okay
yeah so the attack implicitly depends on
the function that I'm attacking and
probably on the true labels okay so so
you can define adversely examples in
number different ways I think the
definition that you could give would be
the function is now different so if it
was wrong before I need to change it to
be even more wrong or maybe to the
correct label or you can give the
definition that it's not equal to the
true label or you can give another
definition which is to say that it's
equal to some targeted label that I have
chosen in advance so you know I want
every image in the test set to become
classified as cat I'm sort of sweeping
all of that under the rug
I'm saying I'm sweeping all of this
under the rug like you can take in lots
of other things too and I just for
notation wanted to make this okay so the
question then is how well do people
perform these evaluations because like
you might think it's kind of simple you
know you write this attack function you
sort of take PGD and run it and then
everything works and so how well do
people do when running these evaluations
so let me give you a case study from
what happened at I Claire 2018 so I
should mention in advance that most of
these papers had very long evaluation
sections by space most of these papers
were roughly one-half evaluation my sort
of color-coded the regions read by the
papers by how much of them were
evaluation and these are papers by very
reputable places trying very hard to get
them right so it's not like these people
were unintelligent or weren't trying so
we be evaluated these and we took all of
the ones that were accepted at iclear
last year and we put four of them out of
scope they were either certified or they
were not white box for bus well they
didn't claim my box robustness of the
remaining ones two of them were correct
and seven of them were broken and I'm
using the words correct and broken very
particularly here by correct I mean the
claims that were made in the paper were
right and by broken I mean the claims
that were made in the paper were largely
wrong I'm not gonna say necessarily
effective or ineffective because sort of
a relative thing yeah
right so the paper made the claim under
the threat model X the accuracy is why
and we tried to lower that accuracy and
failed right yeah we we could not
invalidate it and so I'm going to
believe the claim I mean like someone
else who could try harder could do
better than us but I'm not going to say
that it's wrong unless I know it's wrong
all sort of Ault in general trust
someone unless I can show otherwise okay
great
so what happened why is it that these
were like papers accepted and I clear if
they were all wrong so this is the image
I showed you earlier where this is what
the law service looks like of a standard
neural network turns out what they did
is they made the law surface look like
this and because it's maybe a little
hard to see let me zoom into this one
region here and this is what the law
surface became to look like and if I
showed you this image and said you're
here which way do you go to find an FSO
example like you would go I have no idea
and you just pick a random direction
step that way and hope that you were
right and that's exactly the gradient
does that does right if you are the
surface here and then like though it's
facing this way then you'll go down and
then now you're here and then it's
facing up this way and you step that way
and you just spin into the circle
forever until you stop and basically
make no progress and so this is what
lots of things did they sort of
artificially complicated the law surface
and made it so that you couldn't perform
gradient descent in order to find an
aerosol example yeah so this is all the
light blue region but this is a in like
a 3d rendering which has some artificial
lights with shadows so that you can see
like how the surface looks like that
whole region if you just
the 2d projection so like this we j'en
here corresponds to a mostly flat region
up there so you know it's not the first
time this happened this has happened
many times before and keeps happening
and sort of I don't know when it's going
to stop but like it's not like these
papers in particular which are wrong
like this is sort of a reoccurring theme
that people like to propose maybe it
looks like the authors were repeating um
I took the ones that I had written there
are other ones that other people have
written a lot right
I enjoy breaking things that's sort of
the thing I find the most fun many other
people do the more constructive thing
which is building things and you need
lots of people doing that to find good
ideas and so I'm glad there are people
doing that it's a lot of fun to break
things and you know right ok anyway
that's not the point of this talk so let
me stop okay yes good I will get to that
in a second
yes I'll get back to it's a good idea to
make the law surface complicated I
disagree so the reason why I disagree is
that the objective we're solving for
okay so let me step back one second
there are two reasons why you might
consider ever so examples interesting
either you have the security mindset I
want if I want to make sure that an
actual adversary can't defeat my system
or you have the m/l mindset if I want to
make machine learning better right like
ever so examples are a consequence of
some failure and machine learning to not
do what humans do and so we might want
we might say that if we had better
machine learning ever so examples
wouldn't exist if you're in this camp
and you've UMich ever so examples as a
consequence of some failure of machine
learning then it's clear that what you
care about is the existence and not the
computational method of finding them and
that if ever so examples exist then it's
bad it's not just bad if they can be
found through PGD so in this camp
clearly we should we should only care
about the existence and not the
computational method for finding them in
the other camp for the security question
so I'm a computer security person I have
my PhD in computer security the security
field decided long ago that making the
adversary think harder is the wrong way
of deciding how good a defense is the
way that you decide how good a defense
is is if after the adversary has thought
as hard as they can
then you quantify the amount of work
they have to do like after having done
that thinking and so what I will
introduce is the set of attacks that
defeat those like this complicated loss
surface just as efficiently as a
standard neural network I just had to
think a little bit more to do it ahead
of time and the reason why is that if
you give me any fixed attack I I can
come up with the defense which causes it
to break in some stupid way that's sort
of uninteresting no matter what you do
likes imagine in traditional security I
have some malware file and it like
executes on your machine and now you
like reverse the bit order a new
processor or something it's probably
gonna break the malware file it's not
because your things that needs more
secure it just I didn't happen to
and break it okay so so what should
happen is the defense says here is
something which is secure and then the
attack goes and tries to evaluate it
this is the order that you should
operate in yes that's how it should be
in security the defender should go first
then the attacker goes I want to say
that if you give me a defense for all
attacks they cannot be effective on this
defense and this is sort of the way that
we this is what I've been doing defenses
are so much harder because a defense has
to work against all attacks but if I
give you a defense that I can break it
by just showing one thing is successful
well I'm going to do is I'm going to
construct an attack which defeats the
ones which the defenses which were pros
previously
yes okay sorry is everyone else okay
okay so if that's clear then let me go
on and tell you about some some things
that we've learned about evaluating
where bust this and this comes basically
in in two forms the first set of lessons
that I want to talk about our lessons of
the form what we've learned from from
doing evaluations in how to do thorough
evaluations and if we have time after
this then I'll talk and a little bit
more detail about how to do good
evaluations but that's less important so
stop me if you have questions here
because this is the more important part
anyway okay so if you look at the brief
history of Defense's you know there have
been lots of defenses and many of them
were broken but the fortunate thing is
that each time they were broken we learn
something by how they broke so there
were some defenses that were proposed
that I Triple E security and privacy
they were learned about this thing
that's called gradient masking it was a
problem with this defense and okay and
there's some other events that were
proposed at iclear 2017 and then we
learned like the attacker objective
function is important to choose and
their defenses they proposed at CCS 2017
and we learned you know transferability
of a personal examples really helps the
attacker a lot and then there were some
things that were proposed by Clerk 2018
and so that we said okay this is
obfuscated gradience this is maybe a
gradient masking on steroids and this is
what I'm going to talk about and I'm
gonna sort of explain explain a little
bit about how that works so I showed you
this picture earlier I showed you this
picture earlier the really ugly loss
surface the key observation is that
while this here looks really bad this
function here looks basically the same
as this function so like there's this
light blue region which is at the top
which is very tall there's this green
region as you go to the right same thing
happens in both of these there's the
dark blue region here there's the dark
blue region here like the law surfaces
look very very similar despite the fact
that these are two differently trained
neural networks
this one's easy to find ever so examples
for this one I know looking at this
picture there amber so examples for but
they're hard to find and so you
shouldn't expect this to be robust like
I can point to the region where it's not
robust and it's right there it's just
finding that might be a little bit
tricky and so what we did is we came up
with maybe a gern
technique for solving this in some cases
that makes it so easy to easier to
evaluate and I want to tell you a little
bit about that one but then and then
gets to sort of some more general
thoughts on this so we're gonna do is
we're gonna fix training descent at
least fixed in terms of the way that
these things broke it so imagine I had
some image of a cat that I'm going to
classify and I had some neural network
I'm gonna feed it through where some of
the layers of the neural network here
colored in purple are difficult to
compute gradients through I've added
some randomness I'm dividing by
something that's numerically unstable
I'm doing something that's confusing to
make it hard to compute gradients
through this thing the forward pass
that's fine I just let it go go compute
the forward pass I get some some logic
values or probability values and then I
compute the backward pass and when I
compute the backward pass I replace this
purple function with this yellow
function I replace it with something
which is a lie but has nice gradients so
if it says symbol R is in in function as
the purple function is possible but the
gradients are nicer so for example if
you're doing pre-processing with the
JPEG compression the thing which should
hold true with JPEG compression is that
oh well now we get lights okay
the finish hold true with now we don't
get lights the thing we should hold true
with JPEG compression is that after you
compress an image you get the original
image back as output like f of X should
roughly be equal to X this is the
property of JPEG compression so on the
backward pass you just pretend JPEG
compression didn't exist
I can't compute gradients or JPEG
compression that would be hard but you
know the derivative of f of X with
respect to X is approximately 1 so I
just pretend it doesn't exist this works
this gives me some gradient value which
isn't the actual true gradient value but
it's a good enough approximation or if I
substitute this value into the gradient
descent up and just repeat this a bunch
of times that I do in regular PGD then I
can break all of these defenses it's a
really simple trick it doesn't actually
take you any more computation
maybe I now like double the number of
gradient steps just because I had to lie
what the gradient op was but this
basically works
and so this is in this one particular
case what you have to do when you break
gradients in this way but you know there
are probably many ways that you could
break gradients and this is not the only
way thing you should do like this isn't
the answer for how to deal with broke
ingredients this is one possible thing
you can consider and so when you in
general when you have a model that you
claim to be robust you have to figure
out what you need to do to recover
useful gradients and then try and attack
it basically the thing here is that
disentangling true or bust miss from
apparent robustness is really
non-trivial especially when we're doing
gradient based operations it's there are
lots of ways to make the gradient point
in the wrong direction and there are
many fewer ways to actually make a
robust model so yeah so this is what
happens when you so this is the image
for thermometer encoding when you do
thermometer encoding one of the defenses
I told you about briefly the wall
surface looks like this and I replaced
it with something that made the law
surface look essentially more like this
but it was pointing a little bit in the
wrong direction but at least this is
differentiable nicely and so the key
observation is that this function here
look similar to this function enough
that on the backward pass book good
I have nine minutes okay
so let me then spend a little bit of
time talking briefly about how to
perform better evaluations and the
reason I expect many of you probably
aren't doing this right now the reason
why you should care about how to perform
good evaluations is that sort of sort of
the number of people doing work on ever
so examples is growing exponentially and
it may be you in the future and so it's
useful to know how to do this correctly
because if you end up writing a paper
which says I want to improve machine
learning section 12 ad vitur example
defense it's useful at least to make
sure that you get the evaluation correct
and so I'm going to step through a
little bit of things that we've learned
about how to do these evaluations so
that you can get it right this is all
from a paper that we wrote that's some
20 page report on how to do evaluations
obviously I can't cover all of it but
I'll sort of give you the highlights
okay so first let me tell you the things
that are warnings that you shouldn't do
and I'll mention that I want to be
actionable with my advice and so I'm
going to give you specific examples and
images from papers that do things wrong
everything I show is sort of standard
practice and everyone gets it equally
wrong don't judge these papers I'm gonna
sort of black out the reasons I don't
that aren't important but I'm going to
show you things from actual papers so
the first thing that's necessary is you
need to actually try and break your
defense
this means you need to after you've
spent six months designing something
think how can I make it fail as good as
possible like and that's really hard to
do and you need to make sure the
adversary is aware of what your defense
is doing it's sort of not okay to say
well what if the adversary doesn't know
anything about my defense no it's no
adversary you've just published a paper
on it any person who cared is going to
read your paper at the very least so
you'd have to assume this okay the next
thing is that you know there are lots of
papers which like have like it looks
like they're doing the right thing when
they have some section called
effectiveness and you think they're
doing the right thing until you get to
like section three point four which says
robustness to the white box attacker
which is one paragraph long in which
case what was all of this doing it was
sort of showing that like if you didn't
try very hard that it's defense
effective which is good I mean it so
that's a low bar but like move this to
the
appendix and make this the resume me
paper okay so this is that I should
mentioned that like held out attacks are
not adaptive attacks you actually need
to design your attacks to be defense you
can't just like not use some attack when
designing your thing and then think it's
like I held out attack codes I don't
know this paper uses them right I mean
it's like we have held out test sets
right like in machine learning you can
imagine how someone might think of a
held out attack as like an attack that I
didn't train on or something this is not
a thing you do okay this is attack
that's called the FG SM right exactly
yes yeah this is the tech let's call def
GSM basically just don't use it it's
simple it works for many things but it's
not meant for evaluations don't evaluate
it and when you evaluate with an axe and
you do gradient based attacks you should
do lots of iterations of gradient
descent it's important because sort of
an attacker who can do ten iterations of
gradient descent can probably do fifty
like it's it's five times more work if
it was worth it ahead of time is
probably worth it after if you can show
me that there's an exponential increase
in the number of iterations of gradient
descent you need that would be
interesting I mean the whole idea of
crypto is like exponential work is hard
but if you have to do an Olaf in
increasing the amount of work to break
the thing it's probably not worth making
it unless you can maybe make the
constant hard should you try to do an
adaptive attack yeah okay so my answer
to this is you should try hard enough so
that all existing approaches fail so a
reason why I'm going to say this is that
sort of in my mind there are two types
of Defense's the ones which are which
are like broken by existing attacks and
they're ones that are broken by new
attacks there are no secure defenses
like you're gonna broken by these things
we know about I think you don't know you
know about and as long as you're not
broken by the things we know about then
someone else can like learn something
new by breaking your defense
like this is good like this is how
research happens right like you say
here's something it stops everything we
know about today and someone else can
come along and say well here's this new
thing we didn't know before but now we
know because I had to break your thing
it's sort of the unfortunate thing is
when I have to write a paper that says I
take this attack I knew about and I
download your code and I run the attack
I knew about on your code and your code
breaks and like me this is unfortunate
because like you've wasted everyone's
time is now they've read your paper and
didn't teach us anything it's like this
is what we want I want to make sure that
I'm not like asking for perfection I
just want to make sure that we learn
something by how the thing fails
gradient descent like everything like
there are like 50 different ways of
people who've named like there's like
momentum squared iterative fast gradient
sign like renovated descent I don't care
what you call it it's all the same
specifically there are like lots of
different names of attacks exactly which
one of those you use is basically
unimportant they all like people written
papers called different things with
attacks introducing name different
things it's like there's an attack
called like the basic intro to method
and there's like PGD so what I mean by
just trying create intersect is I mean
it doesn't matter which of the like ten
attacks that are great in descent you
run you pick one of those and then you
think very hard about how to modify it
to make it beat the defense as well as
possible sometimes you'll get these
tables that have like all of the
possible attack people have developed
before and the accuracy on all of them
those tables are more or less useless
like they could be reduced to one row
which is gradient descent and the
accuracy against it with trying as much
as possible to beat the thing in the
come up with a good loss function that's
the sort of the argument I'm going to
make is like put all your effort into
coming
the boss function and then run something
gradient-based I don't care what that
thing is okay okay a couple just sort of
sanity checks in the line of maybe beans
work if you use more iterations the
gradient descent your attacks do better
it doesn't something have bad has
happened if I give you an unbounded
amount of perturbation budget you should
eventually succeed if you can't succeed
with unbounded perturbations it means
your attack is bad you should take the
attack for example you should probably
do better than then bit like maybe I'll
go to this one you should probably do
better than 20% accuracy on imagenet so
epsilon with 128 here means I can turn
any image to solid gray so you should be
able to at least get 0.1% accuracy on
image net with this because my attack
was just the turn solid gray is
successful at this point down to here
but for this one it wasn't so this means
something is wrong you should always
make sure that like this function is
monotonically decreasing if I give you
more power you should do better this is
so a common thing lots of things do
worse when you give them more power make
sure it's not the case so enough bad
things maybe let me tell you some good
things before I finish whatever attack
happens to be the best when you run them
reporting numbers with respect to that
don't say well this week attack does
worse on my model and so I'm stronger so
you have to evaluate based on whichever
one is the most successful it's really
helpful to me and everyone else when you
plot the accuracy of your model versus
how much distortion the introduced like
this helps diagnose lots of potential
problems here's one that does as well
it's sort of a nice monotonic decreasing
function where they claim something at
point three and after point three things
fall off and I could at least verify
that when you go up to 0.5 it's near
zero this is nice
make sure you do enough iterations of
gradient descent here's a nice figure
from some paper that showed that for
this model they kept seeing increases or
decreases in the accuracy as they went
up from a hundred thousand to a million
iterations of gradient descent I don't
know exactly what's going on here but
it's really interesting that this
happens anything
stop that up here they would have gotten
a number which was six times larger than
the true robustness and exactly what
this means is unclear but it's really
nice that they gave me this result I
don't know what to do with it right now
but I like that they did there are some
things with your gradient for your tax
try one of them see what happens
and finally try random noise randomly is
sort of the simplest thing you could
imagine and if you can't defend against
random noise and you can't defend
against actual attacks the nice thing
here is it's hard to get random noise
wrong and in particular all of the
models that we broke in our eye clear
paper sort of do basically the same on
random noise and so you might like have
expected that if they don't do better
than the baseline on random noise maybe
they don't do better in the baseline
there's a baseline undefended Network I
mean there was really the same way as
meant as like as a rant as a regular
network is but like if they were defense
they're there so examples you might
expect that you better so there's some
theory that says like they should but
I'm sort of running out of time so I
don't want to say any of that just
briefly make my one conclusion statement
which is I think that to understand
episode examples the way that I like to
think about them is you sort of
repeatedly play this a game where you
attack and defend and the defender says
here's a fundamental property of ever so
examples in the attacker says no it's
not and then you repeat back and forth
until you sort of learned the things
that are fundamental by episode examples
and what isn't and we sort of been doing
this we optimizer try and teach
ourselves as much as possible about this
face and hopefully eventually we'll
conclude by sort of learning everything
there is to know so with that thank you
and I'm happy to take any questions
[Applause]
so you showed all these mountain ranges
yeah seem to argue that the truth is
smooth and I'm not sure why that should
be but I was thinking if the truth is
smooth
is there a theory like Nyquist rate
which is how much do I have to sample it
before I actually capture the truth like
if you could tell me what the yeah right
so okay so this is a very interesting
observation could I come with a way of
quantifying this so the concern with
doing this is if I came up with a metric
which said like how good your thing is
like how much your model made the
gradients ugly then like I don't want
someone to optimize against this metric
like any metric like season to become a
good metric one says people optimized
for it right yes but like I would want
to write a paper on it or something and
okay let me show you a sneer here I'm in
here thinking that yeah so hope you
think we should think of them right so I
I think like like we do in crypto which
is that we should look at the polling
like the oh of what for the adversary
and encrypt it we have very nice ways of
defining this in machine learning we
have no ways of timing this but I would
like to have better ways of capturing
this I don't think I have one now but
most things today tend to fail in like
doubling number of iterations like you
sort of do two or three times as much
work and things fail and the reason why
I don't care about the small constants
is like I could probably pick like just
the right learning rate and just the
right step size when running the
gradient descent to make them fail
seem that done yes because those are
actually robust because those are robust
to tractable attacks or because those
are a bust to your attack in cases where
we did we failed which was which was
episode of training a lot of PGD by
madri and others I believe it is the
case that they are robust I yeah I think
so and part of the reason why is because
I and many others have tried to break it
repeatedly over the last two years and
failed yes only but like okay so I can
say that we have on very small networks
verified okay so if you take a tiny
memnos network and you train it with
standard new train with PGD then you can
prove that the very small network is at
least five times more robust when
trained with PGD i can certify this with
mixed agenda linear programming and of
course that cert that that certification
may all go out the window once I make a
bigger network but at least on small
networks this is true
[Applause]